so I guess we might as well get get
started a couple minutes after my name
is Craig Wright and I have the pleasure
of being one of the co-chairs of the
online education committee and we have
the entire most of the committee with us
today and this gathering is sponsored by
the entire committee and I'd be
interested in knowing if I can see some
of the folks on online committee out
there if you're a member of our online
committee please raise your hand lots of
folks up here at the at the Dyson okay
Gary and Tom and Paul Lucas and we have
lots of folks at the diocese as well so
this gathering this afternoon is really
a informational and it's on behalf of
all of us and this is actually the
second of these open forums that we had
we had one this summer and we will be
having another one in January and we
will having yet another one in February
Lucas and I Luca schweinfurt over here
by my side kick I suppose we did most of
the organization of this so we will be
running this that the format that we
plan is the following we have asked
seven presenters that represent
different aspects of online education
seated up here at the at the diocese and
we will introduce them as as the as time
goes on and they will present from five
to ten minutes giving us a sense of the
enormous variety of online education
online initiatives that are being played
out here at Yale today and then after
they present we will presumably that
will take roughly an hour so then we'll
take a five minute break and then we
will open the floor up to questions
questions in the traditional written
form that i can understand and then
lucas tells me we have a new way of
doing this so how are we going to do
this lucas tweet some questions to at
yale underscore online we're doing
you can tweet your questions as the as
the day progresses so as you think of
questions asking individual presenters
please tweet the questions and then Ryan
Pearson it's Eric we're seeing here
we'll collect them during the break
right now working together to are
directing them toward the appropriate
presenter when we come back for
questions and answers we also be a
stretch that handing out paper so you
could write it down you'll have a
Twitter account or prefer not to use the
Twitter okay so i think what we'd like
to to do is start with the person who
knows most about online education here
at yale actually in in many ways and
perhaps in all ways the founder of
online education at yale and that is our
own Diana kleiner Dunham professor of
the history of art she started open Yale
courses which has been a huge and
splendid success so we thought it would
be appropriate today to begin with Diana
maybe she can give us a bit of the
history of how this is developed and
maybe perhaps a give us a hint of her
latest online initiative so Diana if
you'd be kind enough to take over here
we'd be delighted to hear from you
please